something i've been watching
some of the world has been watching
is the
defamation trial brought by johnny depp
against amber hurt
have you gotten a chance to watch any of
it um i haven't watched it but i've read
some reports of it
what's your
analysis on this particular
dynamic we talked about toxicity
in the space of agency and communion
what do you make of this
this relationship
that's presented to the world in its raw
form
you know i don't have strong opinions on
it i think in the this stage in the
trial we've heard from
him primarily we have not and we should
say for people listening in case this is
published a little bit later we have not
heard from
amber hurt right uh in the world
if we heard from heard we're doing that
that's going to be happening this week i
i don't know i think that
i've seen and this is another topic that
i have studied is intimate partner
violence and some of the nastier
um stuff that goes on within
relationships and i think that
um
when this nasty stuff happens sometimes
sometimes it's asymmetrical but
sometimes it's symmetrical in the sense
that they get into these downward
spirals where one is insulting the other
or even with physical violence one
starts pushing together showing how
they're hitting the other and then the
other hits back as you get into these um
cycles and so
uh coming at one point in time
you know in this case of uh johnny depp
and amber heard you know uh years later
and trying to disentangle what actually
went on in their relationship
um i i don't i don't feel qualified even
to do that
well it's fascinating to see so first i
mean i have a lot of opinions um
particularly because i'm just a
um
a fan of johnny depp as a person a fan
of giant depth the actor and the kind of
characters he created the person because
maybe this is fiction maybe this is
reality but they tend to rhyme
and uh mirror each other but
his fascination with hunter s thompson
and then some aspect of him taking on
the hunters thompson personality where
there's just layers upon layers of wit
and humor and it's
and also anxiety and darkness with the
drug use and all that kind of stuff it's
very human very real person
and so you get to one of the beautiful
things about this trial is you get to
basically have a long-form podcast
and you get to reveal the complexity of
this human the humor
under pressure under
uh under stress but also just the
rawness of love the things that love
makes you do or whatever that is what
you know
whatever the things that keeps us in
relationships that are toxic
in that turmoil the hope
the um
the self-delusion
the the the push and pull
of
longing and
um fights yeah like that the ups and
downs whatever the yeah the roller
coaster the roller coaster the the the
makeup sex yeah exactly you know yeah is
it in the questions arise whether that's
the feature or a bug like why do we why
are we drawn to that you mentioned in
mate selection for long-term mate
selection
um i think you said women but i think
maybe both
uh don't want a kind of
you had
scientific and eloquent words to use but
basically basically crazy people
you know yeah you want somebody who's
emotionally unstable yeah yeah so um
uh but here it seems like
maybe maybe we're drawn to that still
yeah rise to the light right well it can
be addictive but um it's not good for
long-term relationships i mean that
characteristic and it and there there is
a stable personality characteristic it
goes under different names anxiety
neuroticism emotional liability
uh et cetera but that's the single
personality characteristic that's that
is most predictive of breakups and
divorces
um and and in studies that i've done
predictive of conflict in couples people
who are emotionally unstable they just
get into a lot of conflict with their
partner they create create havoc
so um and they now they can be exciting
but bad for long-term happiness
they see conflict in order to uh
to attain intimacy
so conflict creates
a creates attention
yeah
and
like
if you take intimacy broadly it it's
it's intimate
well you're like raw fragile you're
right there
yeah well
and i mean there's one hypothesis that
was put forward by um
an israeli biologist named amos amos
zahavi
called uh the the testing of a bond and
so he asked the question like why do
people inflict costs on their part like
even like kissing
you're you're introducing you know it's
a disease vector you know why do people
do these weird things
um
inflicting costs or emotional liability
is a way of inflicting costs and what he
argues is it's the testing of a bond if
the person's willing to tolerate
you know this level of stress this level
of cost imposition then that means they
must be very committed to me and so uh
and i think that's something people do
in romantic
relationships is they they do test the
strength of the bond they they test the
the commitment of the person
and i think it's
i think that's a feature not a bug
in the in the sense that
um
you especially in the early stages of
love romantic love we tend to overly
romanticize and i idealize our partner
so when there's an absence of evidence
we we impute positive values
and
what you this is one of
my recommendations to peop friends that
i know is is uh if you're really
considering a good
long-term commitment to this person
go on vacation with them ideally too
ideally to a a foreign country where
both of you are unfamiliar oh i love it
road trip or something like that yeah so
where where you you experience
unexpected things stresses you get a
flat tire or whatever you encounter and
you see how the person
deals with stress and you see how you
deal with each other under stress and i
think that that's
unless you
have put stress tests on relationships
you really don't know where things stand
yeah that's a beautiful way to put it
i'm a huge fan of that like road trip
and not just
late in a relationship like
day one yeah road trip be not not day
one day negative one before it even
happens to see stress test
uh because it makes everybody better it
creates intimacy or creates it
it creates or destroys
but you know on on the johnny depp
so they they also they both suffer
childhood abuse the one one of the
things that i i took away from the trial
for me it was just
educational i don't get to see uh inside
as most of us maybe don't
like toxic relationships or fights and
so on a lot of things that people maybe
do inside relationships and we don't get
to see it present in such a raw way
so well one of the things i learned is
that
um
you know in terms of partner violence
a woman
too can be violent yeah
absolutely that to me so emotionally and
physically violent
that
um
[Music]
i i almost don't want to uh you know
amber heard i mean
there's there's no limit to my dislike
for that that person in particular uh
because um
because clearly to me at least i stand
with johnny depp to me that guy is full
of love
and
but full of demons because he's drawn to
whatever the chaos that's created there
but also it's just an education for me
that
i i tend to associate sort of men with
violence
and
toxicity and destruction inside
relationships but
it was interesting to see that women too
can be like directly
violent yeah and men too
which was also surprising to me
have the capacity
to stay in such a relationship and to
not walk away which is what i thought as
my in terms of toxic violent
relationships i thought
there's a male figure who will do
emotional and physical mostly physical
violence and then
kind of manipulate the mind
of the female to stay in the
relationship but that dynamic goes but
it can go both ways yeah it does go both
ways and and i think even the
emotional
abuse is sometimes even worse than the
physical abuse i mean you see that in in
studies of uh even like childhood abuse
where it's the emotional abuse that is
the most damaging
what about
the role of jealousy something you also
written about in a relationship
is uh
is that a feature a bug
you cut you started to speak about it
but is
is it good to be
uh jealous of your partner inside of a
relationship how does it go wrong
how
the pros and cons so uh so i've written
a whole book on this uh called the
dangerous passion um why jealousy is as
necessary as sex and love
and
uh i think that uh
one
cut at your question is that um a
moderate so first of all i think it's
it's a feature not a bug in in most
cases so
in the in the sense that
you you have to have an adaptation that
is sensitive to threats to a valued
relationship
okay because
and i think i alluded to this earlier
that just because you're in a
relationship and you're in a
relationship with a desirable partner
doesn't mean that
you know you've finished solving the
problems of mating that you need to
solve because there are threats from the
outside so mate poachers people who try
to lure your partner away for either a
sexual encounter or a more committed
romantic relationship
and then there's also dissatisfaction
within the relationship so your partner
might become
tempted to be sexually unfaithful or
romantically unfaithful or emotionally
unfaithful
and so and so we need
humans
with the evolution of long-term pair
bonding we need adaptations to guard
the relationship and be sensitive to
threats to the relationship
and i think jealousy is one of those i
think that's it's a key one
and now
that i think that
there are a variety of benefits to it
but also a variety of um costs or
downsides to jealousy because we know
that jealousy
male sexual jealousy is the leading
cause of spousal abuse and spousal
violence physical physical violence
probably emotional violence as well or
psychological
violence uh and so that's why i call it
the dangerous passion it's it's it's a
necessary emotion
but it is also a dangerous emotion
leads to homicide
you know leads to uh and
i've said also homicidal ideation which
is intersects with this topic in that
men sometimes women to a lesser degree
develop homicidal ideation about people
who are trying to poach their mates or
who do poach their mates
uh successfully poach their mates so
what jealousy does is it is it alerts
you to a threat to the relationship and
it motivates um
checking out the source of the threat
how threatening is this so think people
tend to increase vigilance
of their partner in the modern world
that includes you know hacking into
their cell phone or computer
monitoring them um
uh
sometimes stalking them uh
but also can include
positive things so it might be that so
one trigger of jealousy is is is a
direct threat to the relationship but
there's another more subtle
trigger of jealousy which is a mate
value discrepancy
so usually when people
mate there's they they assort or pair up
on overall mate value so the in the
american
10 point scale the eights tend to pair
up with the eighths the sixes with the
sixes
the tens with the tens and the ones with
the ones american is their other out of
the scales
uh i i i wonder if the miracle systems
well there's a binary i just don't find
it zero one
sorry but okay i know yeah the eighth
pair is what they had seven yeah yeah so
in general but there are errors in made
selection you kind of alluded to the
that issue earlier that sometimes people
make errors errors inmate selection
which they do so sometimes you think
this person is well matched on mate
value but they're not but then things
change so a let's say uh they're the
same you have two sixes and then all of
a sudden the woman's career takes off
all of a sudden she's
you know uh getting promotion she's uh
uh acquiring wealth she's attracting
men who are of a different
mate value than she previously did well
that triggers jealousy in the guy even
if she swears she's gonna be totally
loyal and she has no signs of leaving or
no signs of infidelity
a mate value discrepancy is going to
trigger jealousy
now what can it do well it can do
in the broadest sense people can do two
classes of things they can do cost
inflicting things or benefit providing
things so the the man in that situation
might
say okay i need to devote more attention
to my partner i need to up my game when
it comes to resource acquisition i need
to
lavish more
attention and gifts on her and so
there's a whole suite of benefit
provisioning things that can help to
reduce that mate value discrepancy
and then there's al also cost inflicting
things that and and and humans
unfortunately do both
both sets of things
yeah i there's also this uh maybe that's
love i notice um
the people i especially
love or have a connection to
romantically or otherwise there's a
feeling like i don't deserve you
so
with friends with so on like i mean i
tend to think that about almost
everything which is why it's a strong
signal when i don't feel it that way
which is like i can't i'm how lucky am i
to have this
uh and that's a good that's a that's a
weird illusion of inflation of value or
something like uh i think that the
positive effect of that is makes what
motivates me to be better
i guess on this 110 skill to be higher
and you just sort of kind of
have to
like it's a nice feature that your mind
sees others that you have affection
towards as
higher value and it forces you to have
that like i i'm a person that
experiences jealousy and that forces me
to be better yeah i get my [ __ ] together
yeah well and i and i think that the the
um sometimes the best relationships are
when both people feel lucky to be with
the other person yes exactly it's
balanced that way and then that's when
you in terms of jobs in terms of going
to the gym all those kinds of things and
um yeah so a little bit of jealousy i
have discussion with those people i
always wonder
there's people in relationships where
like no no they're there's no they never
experience jealousy i wonder what that's
like because they're very successful
relationships but
uh and i always wonder you know i'm
currently single so i always doubt that
i know what the hell i'm doing at all
uh but i i'm definitely somebody that
experiences jealousy and kind of enjoys
jealousy
um like
a little bit
of like missing to me that's like you're
missing the other person yeah well
longing for the other person and here's
another uh interesting wrinkle that i
also talk about in the book is uh
sometimes people intentionally evoke
jealousy in their partner
uh and i think that's also a kind of
testing of a bond uh kind of issue yeah
so and
especially women but i think both sexes
interpret a total absence of jealousy as
a sign that their partner is not
sufficiently committed to them or
sufficiently in love with them
so if you like to say i don't know if
you you go to a party with your partner
and then you
leave the room for some reason you come
back and your partner is passionately
kissing someone else and doesn't bother
you at all yeah um that might be a cue
to the partner that well maybe you're
not very in love with that person are
not very committed to them